[Music]  the south indica war memorial was  erected in 1921 by the south  invercargill borough council admitted  controversy of whether to build a war  memorial or a war memorial pool  to replace the council building the  entire memorial was constructed out of  polish bluff granite  and raised adjacent to what was the  south invercargill town hall  on ellis road on 1956 smaller councils  were amalgamated to create the  invercargill city council  and the land on the site was given to  the ilt alongside the southern hotel  building being next to the hotel is of  little wonder that the memorial was  vandalized  so on the 3rd of august 1961 thanks to a  200-pound grant from the ilt  it was moved to its current spot on what  was the seaward bush railway line next  to what was  saint andrew's church the inscription on  the memorial reads  propatria and memory of those of the  borough who made the supreme sacrifice  in the great war 1914-1918